susan's with us in california hi susan
how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i am an educator and um i'm the sole
provider for my
family of seven because my parents live
with me and
i we are working on paying off all our
debts good um
i will have everything paid off by
december except for my student loans
good my student loans are about 175
000 because i have a specialist in
education
and i qualify for the public service
loan forgiveness plan
because i teach at low-income school
districts
and so i'm wondering do i continue
i make 123. okay uh 123 000.
okay a year all right um
yeah but the the the public loan
forgiveness that you're talking about
the 10-year plan right right yeah you
need to read up on that
because somewhere around uh 200 000
people have applied for it
and so far four got it not four percent
for people right it's not wow i mean
it's it's a complete disaster
um and so the government is that they
have
they are not approving them uh
in a very real sense they just lied but
it's the reason they lied is not because
they set out to lie they're just
incompetent
and they're not getting them approved
and so i don't think that's a good plan
no
i wouldn't count on that now there are
some programs that
you know in a lower uh you know in a
tough school district that there there
are some three-year
and some five-year chunk forgivenesses
sometimes like a thirty thousand or
fifty thousand dollar forgiveness
uh those you can get a hold of in a
reasonable period of time
and those are actually occurring but the
10-year plan
is just not happening it didn't occur so
i would not maybe
i wouldn't i wouldn't hook my boat to
that one your boat's gonna sink dave
matter of fact just before i came in
here with you i was talking to one of
our team members
whose friends had done that signed up
for the 10-year program
followed it to a tee and were denied and
so here they had just spent 10 years of
their lives living in a place they
didn't want to live
thinking this program was going to fix
it well because 10 years ago when it was
launched they didn't give clear
guidelines right
and so the what guidelines were given
people
did right but then there's they changed
the game yeah
and then when it comes in they're just
turning them all down right so they got
to the 10-year mark
got turned down woke up said we're gonna
handle this and in two years they paid
it off themselves
right and so all of you all listening
out there i know your ears are getting
tickled
it's an election cycle it's a topic
that's talked about
we're going to forgive your student
loans we're going to do this and that
and it gets people excited and happy
here's the reality it's not going to
happen
the only way you're going to get that
debt out of your life is if you attack
it you make the sacrifice and you handle
it so
don't put your life on pause don't don't
live in a place you don't want to live
for 10 years thinking something's going
to go away
delete it out of your life the scariest
phrase
in the universe is i'm from the
government and i'm here to help
that should just terrify you and so
yeah that's um you should just be going
like it's halloween right so uh run out
of the house and
run so that that's yeah you're better
off to just
take care of business and uh you got a
lot on your plate
you know you're you've got a good income
thank goodness uh but you got a big debt
there and you got a lot of
responsibility it sounds like at home
and so this is going to be you know it's
going to be a three or four year process
but then there won't be any debt
and if you wait the other way it'll
still be sitting there waiting on you
and
and you'll be um disillusioned
i i hope i'm wrong i hope it turns that
they turn the program around
and they figure out well some way to
keep their word but i don't have any
reason for that
because i haven't seen them do anything
else right i mean
this is brought to you by the same
people who run the dmv you know i'm
missing
so oh my gosh this is the dave ramsey
show